beaucoup de choses entre le pont
jacques-cartier centre ville de montréal
donc ça devient très difficile de passer
avec une solution en tunnel ben t'as
difficiles dans beaucoup de cas
impossible difficile ou impossible
c'est impossible ou oui impossible
jean-marc carbone ou donnait une
entrevue boulevard rené lévesque en mars
dernier le charbon bonsoir il est avec
nous en direct mais charbo vous me
disiez à l'époque c'était impossible un
harpon tunnel et vous aviez déjà dit en
images ce après s'écrouler et tout ça or
ce n'est pas impossible
lorsqu'on échoue on est revenu
aujourd'hui de façon détaillée pour
aller jusqu'au bout de la démarche pour
dire oui comme le journaliste dont j'ai
oublié le nom a précisé vraiment au
début on avait regardé les solutions
vraiment importante sous
difficile ada sous les lignes de métro
entre les lignes de métro puis en
amenant les tunes au final là ils ont
dit mais pourquoi est ce qu'on regarde
pas un peu au dessus des vignes de
profiter de la pente naturelle pour
pouvoir amener une solution d'un tunnel
de surface cours en surface et puis ça
ça fonctionne c'est pas une un projet
qui se réalise avec un tunnelier ça va
se réaliser avec une aveu c'est plus
court mais c'est une solution qui est
vraiment intéressante puis c'est dans le
même cas de ce qu'on fait dans nos
études c'est à dire qu'on part d'un
point on est on part d'un projet de
référence puis on essaye d'amener des
améliorations tout au long mais s'il n'y
avait pas eu monsieur arbaud tout s'est
levée de boucliers de gens qui ont dit
on va défigurer le centre-ville etc etc
il faut qu'on poursuivre la réflexion
sur un tunnel vous vous n'aviez pas
l'intention de faire aucun tunnel que ce
soit dans le fond
nous on reste on a toujours la même
démarche on l'a eue depuis le début du
projet on continue d'avoir on l'avait
sur leur haine
débuts sur la même phase de fauche
toujours chercher on part d'un projet de
référence on l'optimisait on a des
consultations publiques on écoute on
essaie de ramener les meilleures
solutions d'un point de vue pragmatique
réalisable et réaliste ok mais on
reconnaît ensemble que c'était donc
possible qu'une portion tunnel ce que
vous trouviez impôts c'est bien peu de
talent auquel jouent oui c'est possible
on arrive aujourd'hui avec une solution
pour avoir une portion tunnel très bien
mais les eaux du tunnel dont on parlait
way qui inquiète non cela ils sont
toujours impossible et je pense que
c'était vraiment le débat important
c'était une partie apportant bon mais ce
qui m'amène à l'autre question parce que
vous êtes encore sur le lin l'ensemble
la portion centre-ville ça sera pas un
tunnel vous continuez à dire c'est
impossible alors pourquoi ce moment là
faire un tunnel de cinq cents d'abord il
est de 500 2 600 mètres passe à ses
dépens jusqu'où on compte ça va 2 jeanne
mance bleury
mais cette portion là pourquoi faire un
petit tunnel dans le fond si le gros du
centre-ville sera en aérien
parce que ça permet d'avoir une bonne
intégration
à la fin ça aussi des avantages cette
station souterraine ça permet d'avoir
une connexion directe avec tout le
réseau souterrain de montréal ce qui en
est rien et est plus complexe et puis ça
permet aussi donc tout le réseau ça veut
dire tous les autres lignes de transport
que ce soit le futur m que ce soit la
ligne orange ou la ring verte via le
réseau souterrain ça permet aussi de
mettre en place une arrière-garde c'est
à dire de d'avoir une zone de
retournement des trains à l'arrière de
la gare qui permet d'augmenter la
fréquence théorique futur du projet
quelles sont les prochaines étapes
monsieur à rebonds
on en est où il ya un comité qui regarde
je pense qu'il regarde exactement ce
qu'ils ont le mandat de tout regarder
c'est pas clair pour moi
le comité d'experts on la crée en fait
je pense quand on avait je vous avais
parlé aux dires va mettre en place un
comité d'experts pour regarder toute la
problématique de l'intégration
urbaine et architecturale de l'ensemble
du projet d'accord et puis on a présenté
depuis on a ce comité dans d'experts a
été mis en place avec le gouvernement du
québec ces experts on a eu huit réunions
avec eux on a examiné on leur présente
l'ensemble des dossiers la même façon
que les dossiers qu'on a présenté là
dedans analyse technique de etc 2
pourquoi pas les solutions en tunnel
enterré elles représentent ces dossiers
là et a failli feront un rapport jeu par
rapport à l'intégration architecturale
urbaine donc la prochaine étape j'avais
su ce fut long mais la prochaine étape
c'est qu'on va présenter cet automne
l'ensemble de la la programmation
architecturale et urbaine pour toute la
partie interne ils reviennent ils vous
continuer à plaider que la partie
aérienne qui est la majeure partie du
projet
pourra s'intégrer harmonieusement
à une cité comme on rien oui continue à
plaider ce à dire ça sera au fait tous
les efforts ce on est vraiment conscient
de la problématique d'intégration
et il faut réaliser cette intégration
mais et on met tous les efforts pour le
faire
si le gouvernement du québec voyant que
j'ai pas la grogne prenait de l'ampleur
sur le l'aérien si le gouvernement du
québec vous dit bert
les il mettait toute la gomme fait un
tunnel sur tout le centre ville est ce
que vous diriez jean marc herbaux mais
c'est terminé on n'est plus là dedans
c'est on ne le fera pas parce que c'est
soit impossible soit tellement couture
que ça deviendrait impossible
j'ai un pompe ce qu'on a aujourd'hui on
a dévoilé tout l'ensemble des études et
toute notre analyse au travers de ça ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est réaliser un
tunnel sur toute la longueur c'est
rentrer dans un projet qu'il est
impossible de circonscrire tant d'un
point de vue financier que d'un point de
vue de coups et il n'y a pas un
contracteur dans le monde qui prendrait
le risque réaliser ce genre de projet la
clé en main il ya je veux pas rentrer
dans les détails donc à la fin pour ma
note pour ma part en plus mais pour la
position de cdpq infra ce serait pas
réaliste de recommander à qui que ce
soit de s'engager dans un projet dont on
ne sait pas définir les limites est ce
que vous pourriez je vous laisse là
dessus jama carbo est ce que vous
pourriez dans un cas comme celui-là qui
y possède cinq enceintes à metz pour la
discussion tout au rien dire bambins
cdpq se retire merci bonsoir on ça nous
intéresse plus
on veut pas rentrer dans un projet comme
ça j'ai encore une fois peu pâle
recommandé c'est un projet qu on
recommandera pas on peut pas leur
commander et recommanderait pas un
gouvernement c'est la même il n'y a pas
de différence de dire entrer dans ce
projet là je pense qu'on a mis les
analyses pour le montrer très bien jean
marc herbaux on va suivre ensemble ce
projet plus les plus les documents sont
publiques plus la discussion c'est clair
oui n'est ce pas oui un peu fait parce
que les études fait un bout de temps
qu'on lui demande bon je pense qu'on a
on a eu des discussions en marche en
avant ils m'avaient un premier rapport
passe il n'a publié un deuxième rapport
on a eu fini des rapports
complémentaires avec d'excellents
résultats en avec le comité d'experts on
échange tous ces résultats là avant de
les rendre publiques
je pense qu'on tient un bon rythme a
dévoilé des documents à expliquer et à
être transparent vis-à-vis du
dévoilement du projet jean marc herbaux
président chef de la direction de céder
pq est fera merci beaucoup de nous avons
parlé merci